bouygues n'a pas échappé à la règle
devenir un véritable château fort et le
château fort une heure pour parcourir
500 ans d'histoire
le château de rambouillet propose des
visites chaque vendredi à 11h et 15h en
extérieur dans les jardins avec une
jauge réduite 5 personnes maximum et
masque obligatoire
ce jour-là une mère et ses deux enfants
sont venus admirer les extérieurs
notamment les temps ça fait un moment
qu'on n'a pas eu l'occasion de faire des
visites guidées et là l'occasion s'est
présentée on a sauté dessus parce qu'ils
aiment beaucoup les châteaux et c'était
l'occasion de faire quelque chose
pendant les vacances avec le qu'est ce
que tu as pensé de cette visite très
bien qu'est ce que tu as aimé
surtout les explications des rois à
travers les jardins et les façades du
château la visite retrace les
différentes époques de l'histoire de
l'édifice et les grands personnages qui
y sont passés pas de mort princières et
royales résidence dampier ensuite
présidentielle un an qu'un c'est très
riche en histoire en histoire de france
la réservation se fait uniquement sur
les sites internet du château prochaine
visite vendredi 30 avril à 15h le
créneau de 11h affiche déjà complet